Oh [Music]
what is going on do to now there are few
things that everyone is 5-speed when
their kid when you grow up in an Asian
house with one of the many aspirations
is that up becoming a don't dare don't
listen
Sena pushing up baby stick your hose and
vagina
we can sing not all of us are made to be
doctors and it's okay so it's all about
knowing yourself so y'all don't know
what it is parents your child is not
going to be a doctor
yeah a 2.6 GPA shaky hands and a speech
impediment he ain't gone Gershon P and
Goku [ __ ]
he ain't gonna [ __ ] why does he have to
be a doctor hmm why can't he have a
career that he'll be read and won't
endanger people's lives be a doctor the
[ __ ] before the Bandit is you you want
your daughter to be a surgeon beyond she
can barely hold a spoon the mountain
tops to the cereal the girl shakes so
much she was the number one tambourine
player at a church for six years you
want her to be a surgeon you didn't
think what was the whole time you want
to chocolate then maybe he or she did
not want to become a duck you didn't
pick up on the signs I told your
chompers on the enzyme with cancer you
know what she told me she told me she
would find a way to cure it just because
you have the brains for it
it doesn't mean you could do it as a
career there has to be a reason more
than just for the money because you're
given up a decade of your life or more
but something that you want to do for
the rest of your life
let's be honest for a second
you don't really do you you tell people
that you're in pre-med and you want to
be adopted because it oppresses them but
in all honesty you don't know [ __ ] every
time you open your mouth
it's just [ __ ] you sound like one of
those performances my neighbourhood they
just started going back to school so
they're trying to use big words darn for
like the other day I felt and I put that
part of my brain thought the [ __ ]
Apollonia [ __ ] come the one you got the
fun work don't get smacked fool look at
your GPA look at that [ __ ] and tell me
you have a future in medicine your GPA
is roughly at a two point I ain't get in
the medical school
you have not put in the time and effort
to be put in a position that allows you
to diagnose someone else's help but tell
you something if you ever become a
doctor that you had to kill me [ __ ]
don't worry I saved myself don't cross
the edge and try to save my life I'm not
flat and what's in the hands for like a
back massage or something let me wrap it
up for you not now Kudo
no seriously let me do it I said no I
don't understand how you had the
sorriest GP on earth and you get sad and
depressed when you found out that you
didn't get into med school what you
thought that [ __ ] was easy step your
game up player because everybody's
gunning for your position don't try to
go into a career for someone else and
don't do it just because someone else
tells you to do it you have any idea how
many Asian kids I know that go through
the whole pre-med route and graduate and
find out that they don't want to do this
as a career
what happens with them they graduate
with the [ __ ] to the loans and then they
go back to school try to do what they
really want to do in the first place
okay you want to be adopted because
someone else tells you but I'm gonna
start off with a very good program give
yourself a physical take it head out
your ass and find it ballsack you grow a
pair do not waste your time with
something for the wrong reasons or if
you do not have the dedication or the
motivation to do it
now in the near future when you have
figured out if you want to become a
physician or not don't forget your board
itself because I do got that medical
insurance so um hook it up play me
well actually my health issues are
weight-related not pug it's cool it's
good what I've got yeah I keep Betty
rabbit Simon case they wanna ride me
keep mo bills in the Kospi if I figure I
can look cocky things might get low
right here we go
back it up
[Laughter]